good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
studying today is SCP 166 object class
Euclid special containment procedures as
CP 166 can be kept safely in a minimal
security environment as SCP 166 is
housed in a standard Class B suite at
site 17 with the following alterations
the adjacent suite has been read into a
local observation post translucent
acrylic panels have been placed in the
approach corridor and staging area to
prevent direct line-of-sight into the
containment suite from the exterior
hallway warning signs have been placed
throughout the containment area
indicating that no male personnel are
permitted in the area reasonable
requests for personal items and
modifications to the containment suite
may be granted upon approval by a level
4 or higher authority to date SCP 166
has requested a copy of the Holy Bible
do a Remus Challinor revision granted a
Catholic rosary granted access to a
Catholic priest for confession mass and
other sacraments denied various books
and magazines mostly religious in nature
granted pending review and approval of
contents a telephone with which to
contact the Abbess of the
convent in Cornwall England granted ASEP
166 is to be allowed one hour of
telephone time a week to this phone
number only SCP 166 is generally content
to remain in her quarters as long as she
is provided with entertainment in the
form of religious materials books
television and art supplies in return
for her cooperation in her own
confinement SCP 166 is to be allowed a
12 hour excursion away from site 17 to
an adjacent uninhabited island no more
than once per month limited release
protocol 19 a is observed in these cases
with a added restriction that no male
personnel are to be allowed within 500
meters of scp-162 6 during transport and
no male personnel are to be allowed on
the island during her stay as even the
lightest clothing tends to cause
pressure ulcers bed sores within 45
minutes of constant wear SCP 166 is
allowed to go nude for medical purposes
garments and bed linens are to be made
of long staple cotton and should be
changed weekly male staff are forbidden
from viewing or entering the direct
vicinity of scp-162 6 violation of this
order will result in immediate
disciplinary review and possible
termination at least one female staff
member must remain in adjacent
observation room at all times
and maintain direct visual observation
of SCP 166 through viewing slits or
closed-circuit television in order to
minimize the risk of accidental exposure
all cameras and windows shall be
equipped with translucent filters with
at least 50% exclusion of detail no a
permanent record shall be kept of any
photographic evidence of Si p160 Six's
appearance SCP 166 requires no
sustenance save approximately 1 CC of
human semen administered orally on a
weekly basis arrangements have been made
with a local sperm bank for this purpose
on-site procurement will be
carried out in emergencies only despite
the fact that SCP 166 requires no other
sustenance the subject can consume
normal human food and does do some jutsu
SCP 166 is many health issues medical
evaluations should be carried out at
least once per week description SCP 166
appears to be a female human in her late
teens of average height and slender bill
medical and physiological analysis
indicates several deviations from the
baseline human norms including
accelerated hair growth approximately 20
centimeters per month vulnerability to
airborne particulate matter such as
cigarette smoke and aerosols which can
induce symptoms similar to an acute
asthma attack increased sensitivity to
pressure ulcers and alterations and
dietary requirements SCP 166 is noted
for her unusual effect upon human males
upon establishing visual contact with us
EP 166 100% of human males tested
attempted immediate sexual contact
regardless of their normal sexual
orientation in approximately 70% of
these test subject the impulse faded
after being removed from SCP 166 his
presence in 30 percent of these cases
however the desire turned into obsession
resulting in violent attempts to gain
access to a CP 166 Class A amnestics
were efficacious in 43 percent of these
cases the remainder required termination
SCP 166 is effect on males causes her no
small amount of distress not least due
to her desire to follow a monastic life
based on the principles of chastity
poverty and obedience for this reason
and others contact between her and any
human male is strictly prohibited
addendum 166 a circumstances of
retrieval SCP 166 was originally
retrieved from a convent in Cornwall
England
according to the nuns she had originally
been delivered to the convent by a
person of indistinguishable features who
claimed that she was the offspring of an
elder creature of great power and
provided instructions for her care
all attempts to locate the mother have
been unsuccessful to date SCP 166 was
raised by nuns in a cloistered
environment until a young man subject a
who sneaked into the convent to visit
one of the novices accidentally caught
sight of her three days later
subject a became violent and attacked
the convent attempting to gain access to
SCP 166 subject a proceeded to kill one
nun and severely injured three others
before being neutralized by force a
foundation operative consulting with a
local priest regarding an unrelated
matter heard of the incident and
proceeded to the scene when he too
became enamoured the operative
immediately cut off contact placed
himself into confinement and requested a
female operative from command to take
over the retrieval operation agent
Beatrix Maddox made contact with the
Mother Abbess shortly afterward
negotiating the transfer of scp-162 six
to foundation facilities for containment
and research addendum 166 e text of a
letter unknown origins placed n SCP 166
is sweet
dear I first met your mother when she
was a girl she had hooves for feet and
Starlight in her eyes she was beauty and
nature and I killed her with my own two
hands
Eden isn't a place it's a state of being
they wanted to take us back to it I
stopped them
I took paradise away from us for a
second time I have never regretted my
actions on that day except one that when
you first met me on that day you saw
your father put a bullet into the head
of your mother I make no excuses on my
explanation I hope you understand why I
did what I did I hope you forgive me I
love you I wish I could have done more
for you the best I could do was leave
you in the hands of kind and loving
people and hoped they would raise you in
my place from what I've seen they did
well I'm sorry you can stay with them
I'm sorry they've brought you to this
place I promise to do my best to make
sure you stay here is pleasant I promise
to keep you safe happy 16th birthday
honey
your father
that about does it for today thank you
all for listening if indeed you still
are and you are all dismissed goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Desmond Hoskins Andrey Bichette dr.
mortis Cody tench Pierce M Hamlin sy7
actual rebellion fidelia's untie verbal
if you would like a personalized thank
you at the end of each of my videos on
some other cool stuff as well as at
patreon.com forward slash the volgen
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you